for this year's super bowls frito-lay
actually has several ads in the game
one of them actually is a joint ad for
the first time with flamin hot cheetos
but it's also an introduction for flamin
hot cool ranch dorito which is being
introduced and promoted for the first
time spicy salty snacks they've been
massively popular in recent years the
category is growing 12
in the last four years i mean there's
real momentum behind flaming heart
itself and we know that 46 of gen z love
flamin hot it inspired us to then take
these two
really well known super bowl brands
and pair them up for the first of its
kind flaming hot campaign the
celebrities that are working with
frito-lay for the spot are megan the
stallion and also charlie puth both are
wildly popular musicians right now that
come from very different genres and
for the last couple of weeks they've
been dropping hints and teasers as a
part of this campaign where they're
showing up at their trailer for for the
ad and and you're seeing you know paw
prints and charlie's and you're seeing a
sloth hand outside of megan the
stallions
in the at itself you've got someone
that's walking through the jungle and
they go up into a tree when all of a
sudden the doritos and cheetahs fall out
of the bag under the ground and pretty
soon a sloth notices both bags and
starts slowly creeping over to it but
suddenly other animals appear they're
vying to get both bags as the commercial
progresses charlie and megan both show
up by just their voices actually and so
they start beat boxing and kind of
singing to the 1986 sultan pepper
classic push it oh baby baby but baby
baby fans making the stalin will
probably recognize her classic ad-lib
that she makes in the form of a bird
actually during the song
it's interesting because both megan the
sally and charlie puth show up in the
teasers for the commercial but in the
actual ad it's just their voices tell us
more about the decision to use just
their voices rather than um their faces
in the ad
one of the things that rachel and i have
talked about a lot is that
you know how
each year how do we do something
unexpected and different like how do we
you know reinvent the wheel and we've
used a lot of celebrities in the past
but we've never used them in this way so
we could took more of kind of a pixar
approach we did want to see that you
know they were the voices so you'll see
you know we did three teasers leading up
to our
spot i think it's also interesting to
put this ad into the context of how
doritos and cheetahs have shown up over
the last few super bowls in the past
they've used other celebrities like
matthew mcconaughey for an ad they also
use m.c hammer and an ad for cheetos
featuring his classic song can't touch
this
can't touch this when you think about
how many years that our partnership has
been working through super bowl looking
for that innovation every year and how
do we create more disruption more
unexpected moments uh you know we
continue to look at all the ways in
which we can do that well we don't know
how much friday paid either celebrity to
be in their commercial it's often really
expensive to get some of the biggest
names in pop culture to appear in one of
advertising's biggest moments which is
every year the super bowl we know that
of consumers are
choosing snacks for game day that's huge
it's one of the biggest moments of the
year for us from an overall snacking
occasion we need to be present and we
need to be playing a big role and so
that
fundamentally from a business rationale
perspective sets the stage for us to be
there you know every year is a is a new
challenge it's a really fun experience
but it's a lot of work and it's not
without a lot of thought and rigor in
the process
and innovation is always top of mind we
we say innovate or die
[Music]
you